[НА правки 4_1 / 00:35] A: Никита Александрович, здравствуйте.
[НА правки 4_1 / 00:37] B: О, привет,
[НА правки 4_1 / 00:38] B: Жень, привет.
[НА правки 4_1 / 00:39] A: Добрый день.
[НА правки 4_1 / 00:40] B: Да, да, в Рио сейчас.
[НА правки 4_1 / 00:45] B: Че, как делишки?
[НА правки 4_1 / 00:46] A: Да нормально, вот я три дня назад в Москву вернулся, хожу в офис, сейчас пока университета нет, чем-то себя занимаю.
[НА правки 4_1 / 00:58] A: вот
[НА правки 4_1 / 00:58] B: То
[НА правки 4_1 / 00:58] A: он но
[НА правки 4_1 / 00:58] B: есть ты себя специально снял офис, чтобы туда ходить?
[НА правки 4_1 / 01:02] A: у меня у партнера есть офис и мне не приходится снимать но мы оплачиваем и скидываемся на коммуналку на уборщицу там на еду покупаем и вот ходим часто и вот мы только только пришли но мы так мы знаете вы знаете мы занимаемся что думаем что там
[НА правки 4_1 / 01:28] A: пойдет типа такого то есть какой-то проект
[НА правки 4_1 / 01:31] B: Ну,
[НА правки 4_1 / 01:31] A: приходит
[НА правки 4_1 / 01:32] B: понятно.
[НА правки 4_1 / 01:32] A: и вы
[НА правки 4_1 / 01:34] B: Ну, это хорошо,
[НА правки 4_1 / 01:35] B: хорошо. Видишь, у нас тут проектов громадьон.
[НА правки 4_1 / 01:40] B: Вот.
[НА правки 4_1 / 01:40] B: Давай, короче, вот по нашим насущным проблемам.
[НА правки 4_1 / 01:44] A: Кстати, я исправил, я полностью исправил SEO,
[НА правки 4_1 / 01:48] A: там была, короче, такая штука, что из-за того, что динамическая страница была,
[НА правки 4_1 / 01:55] A: а это не то, что плохо, что динамическая страница, она просто не так много информация отдавала, и я увеличил, чтобы когда...
[НА правки 4_1 / 02:08] A: робот заходил, чтобы он полностью получал эту страницу, а генерировал только там ну графики же ему не нужно.
[НА правки 4_1 / 02:15] A: Вот, и я
[НА правки 4_1 / 02:16] B: еще Пока.
[НА правки 4_1 / 02:17] A: полностью подключился к API метрики и сейчас напрямую сгружаю все данные с метрики, ну все показы и так далее и Ишку отправляю, чтобы он мне таблицы выводил такие, можно было отслеживать там и что-то исправлять там в контексте и так далее.
[НА правки 4_1 / 02:39] B: Ну,
[НА правки 4_1 / 02:39] B: это хорошо,
[НА правки 4_1 / 02:40] B: смотри,
[НА правки 4_1 / 02:41] B: то есть, короче говоря,
[НА правки 4_1 / 02:42] B: вот у нас, почему я вот, то есть, ты это сегодня вот сделал, да, сегодня у нас 28,
[НА правки 4_1 / 02:48] B: посмотрим,
[НА правки 4_1 / 02:49] B: потому что, почему я вот заметил, потому что у нас постоянно,
[НА правки 4_1 / 02:52] B: видишь,
[НА правки 4_1 / 02:53] B: он добавляет, удаляет что-то, то есть, видишь, у него,
[НА правки 4_1 / 02:58] B: как бы, если вот Яндекс.Вебмастер посмотреть,
[НА правки 4_1 / 03:00] B: то он то добавляет, то потом удаляет.
[НА правки 4_1 / 03:04] B: Добавляет, вот если там поподробнее как бы это раскрыть, вот, видишь, то есть тут удалил три, удалил одну, там вот здесь шесть удалил, три удалил, да, и вот видно, как он там удаляет какие-то страницы, видишь, там здесь вот это PWP удалил там, 25 числа,
[НА правки 4_1 / 03:26] A: Mm
[НА правки 4_1 / 03:26] B: то
[НА правки 4_1 / 03:27] A: -hmm.
[НА правки 4_1 / 03:27] B: есть он их как будто бы не,
[НА правки 4_1 / 03:30] B: короче, хочет оставлять, то есть он их то добавил, то...
[НА правки 4_1 / 03:34] B: в байду плюс вот посмотри обязательно чтобы у нас вот эти все дублирующиеся тайтлы
[НА правки 4_1 / 03:42] A: Да, я уже исправил
[НА правки 4_1 / 03:43] B: да то есть вроде
[НА правки 4_1 / 03:44] A: уже
[НА правки 4_1 / 03:44] B: бы когда
[НА правки 4_1 / 03:44] A: сегодня.
[НА правки 4_1 / 03:44] B: просто когда заходишь на страницу там вроде все нормально но вот если посмотреть то что вчера да вот просто source код который она дает видишь
[НА правки 4_1 / 03:59] B: То есть это просто главная страница. То есть хотя я вот эту страницу
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:03] A: А попробуйте сейчас тоже
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:05] B: зашел.
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:05] A: сразу нажать,
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:06] B: Ну допустим,
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:06] A: он
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:06] B: я сейчас.
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:07] A: должен побольше быть сейчас.
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:12] B: Ну вот сейчас попробуем.
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:15] B: Вот ресурс.
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:18] B: Вот сейчас он отдает нормально.
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:21] B: Вот.
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:23] A: Вообще
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:23] B: сейчас
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:24] A: сегодня исправил просто.
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:25] B: лучше потому что он просто на да да да то есть сейчас хорошо то есть пойди он должен заиндексировать то есть главное чтобы у нас были смотри вот эти вот описание да вот
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:37] A: Да.
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:41] B: мне конечно бы надо смотри вот этот поменять бы описание видишь ну вот этот тайтл во первых на главной странице видишь потому что тайтл на главной странице
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:52] B: Он у нас, типа, про инфляцию?
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:56] B: Все, кстати, вот непонятно почему.
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:57] B: А, это description так или где title?
[НА правки 4_1 / 04:59] A: А вот чуть-чуть выше двадцатая строка.
[НА правки 4_1 / 05:07] B: Вот смотри.
[НА правки 4_2 / 00:00] A: задоловки страниц то есть он делает просмотры да там вот эти 130 сегодня да вот этот прогноз инфляции которые экономические данные данные вот то что показывается вот здесь и вот это вот то что по идее должно быть в тайтле то есть как будто он как-то не так их это
[НА правки 4_2 / 00:25] A: То есть вот с этим немножко нужно бы что-то посмотреть вот этот момент.
[НА правки 4_2 / 00:33] B: Хорошо, я тебя отметил то, чтобы заголовки, да,
[НА правки 4_2 / 00:37] A: То есть то, что мне кажется странным, это смотри, то, что у нас, когда заходы идут по рекламе.
[НА правки 4_2 / 00:53] A: Допустим, они нормально отображаются, то есть можно вот в Twitter посмотреть, что человек что-то там делает.
[НА правки 4_2 / 01:03] A: То есть, видишь, показывается, он что-то там листает, куда-то заходит,
[НА правки 4_2 / 01:08] A: что-то делает.
[НА правки 4_2 / 01:11] A: Когда у нас, допустим, очень часто показывает, смотри, как.
[НА правки 4_2 / 01:19] A: Время на сайте 18, вот у нас есть какой-то фанат из Казани, который уже 58 раз заходил.
[НА правки 4_2 / 01:32] A: И он заходит, ну что-то он смотрит, да, вот смотри,
[НА правки 4_2 / 01:36] A: 6 просмотров, 18 минут,
[НА правки 4_2 / 01:38] A: но при этом если вы выключаешь, то просто ничего не показывается.
[НА правки 4_2 / 01:45] B: Да, вижу.
[НА правки 4_2 / 01:47] A: То есть движ просто, он просто не записывает это.
[НА правки 4_2 / 01:51] A: И то же самое происходит с заходами, которые из песковых систем.
[НА правки 4_2 / 02:01] A: То есть вот у нас, допустим, сегодня было там 13 заходов.
[НА правки 4_2 / 02:08] A: И все они, да,
[НА правки 4_2 / 02:10] A: вот какие-то такие, что он там записывает там ноль, пять секунд там,
[НА правки 4_2 / 02:15] A: при этом ничего нет,
[НА правки 4_2 / 02:17] A: то есть вот тоже самое ноль секунд, то есть просто заходишь, ну, тот самый,
[НА правки 4_2 / 02:22] A: ну,
[НА правки 4_2 / 02:23] A: как бы не может, и при том, что вот всего, да, у нас, допустим, если посмотреть месяц, да,
[НА правки 4_2 / 02:33] A: то есть всего у нас получается список систем 102,
[НА правки 4_2 / 02:37] A: да, человек.
[НА правки 4_2 / 02:38] A: Все эти люди не посмотрели ни один, больше одной страницы, больше пяти секунд.
[НА правки 4_2 / 02:45] A: Но это просто не может быть такого.
[НА правки 4_2 / 02:49] A: То есть как будто бы что-то происходит, когда либо люди переходят просто по прямому заходу, либо по...
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:05] A: То есть с поисковой системы.
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:07] A: Ну, я не знаю, как это вот объяснить.
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:12] A: То же самое вот здесь, да, там по ссылкам на сайтах. То есть вот нормально он отображает заходы с рекламы, допустим.
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:20] A: Ну, может быть, это как-то действительно так.
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:23] A: Ну, допустим, давай посмотрим.
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:24] A: Хотя вот здесь вот, допустим, прямой заход, он записал нормально.
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:30] A: Сейчас почему-то такие там,
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:32] B: Я
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:32] A: перестав нормальная
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:32] B: посмотрю, по-моему почему
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:34] A: атаки.
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:34] B: такое нападение.
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:36] A: Вот видишь, вот был прямой заход,
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:40] A: только здесь почему-то,
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:41] A: что это у него там,
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:44] A: вот это что за хрень, что
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:48] A: -то сломалось с
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:50] B: А это когда она
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:51] A: квартальной инфляцией.
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:52] B: была,
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:53] B: когда смотрела?
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:56] B: Какая дата точная?
[НА правки 4_2 / 03:57] A: 11.26 сегодня,
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:00] A: сегодня с утра, давай-ка я посмотрю сейчас,
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:05] A: то есть что-то у нас там может,
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:07] B: вот, Я просто диплоил заново, он мог мой фикс не подтянуть, который я делал.
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:13] A: вот, сломалось, сломалось,
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:15] B: Да,
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:16] B: или да-да,
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:17] A: что,
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:17] B: да, не
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:17] A: то есть он, то есть он плюс, плюс, плюс то сделал,
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:20] A: вот, и смотри,
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:22] A: то есть вот этот вот да.
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:26] A: как бы за год ну тоже датой ты а или вроде ты разобрался да
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:33] B: Да,
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:33] A: то есть 370
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:34] B: да, да, я их поменял.
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:36] A: то есть тут что-то изменилось да
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:40] B: Я это делал тоже.
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:41] B: Я вот когда писал то, что я правки сделал,
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:43] B: я и в том числе, чтобы переписать графики и кнопочки, чтобы их оформить по смыслу, ну,
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:50] B: по логике, как они должны быть.
[НА правки 4_2 / 04:54] A: смотри давай тогда когда меняется график что прогноз тоже тогда столбиками потому
[НА правки 4_2 / 05:00] B: Столбиком.
[НА правки 4_2 / 05:00] A: что получено получается как-то ну несоответствие то есть тут у нас было как бы линия линия да ну и соответственно тоже давай ее под под вот видишь она затемнена немножко давай прогноз тоже под ну то есть сделаем там синеньким ну то есть
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:00] A: Соответствующее.
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:01] B: Угу, в одной, ну да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:02] A: А
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:03] B: чтобы они
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:03] A: так,
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:03] B: были.
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:03] A: в принципе,
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:04] A: так,
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:06] A: в принципе, тут нормально.
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:10] A: Ну вот квартальное надо поправить.
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:13] A: И вот что-то у нас, видишь, с этими, с осветами.
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:18] B: А, с правыми.
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:19] A: И что?
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:20] A: Да, да, да, обычно.
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:23] A: Но это даже
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:24] B: А
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:24] A: не
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:24] B: кстати,
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:25] B: вот видели,
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:25] A: здесь,
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:25] B: я туда нам,
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:25] A: да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:26] B: я нам графику Forex Economy подставил, чтобы этот, если скринили, да.
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:32] A: поставила, она почему-то закрыла. Ее надо поставить сверху, вот сюда, чтобы ее трудно было вырезать.
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:41] A: То есть, а здесь можно просто принт-скрин и вырезать ее, ее отрезать.
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:46] A: Вот, то есть, как бы.
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:48] A: Ээээ, когда её бы лучше вот сюда куда-нибудь там вставить.
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:53] B: Я могу ее вообще на самом
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:54] A: Ну то есть
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:54] B: деле сделать желтой под свет этого дизайна.
[НА правки 4_3 / 00:59] A: Ну можно, можно, можно, да, жёлтый. Но я к тому, что здесь нарушается эта... ось.
[НА правки 4_3 / 01:07] A: Видишь, что, ну,
[НА правки 4_3 / 01:09] A: как
[НА правки 4_3 / 01:12] A: бы, может быть её вот сюда поставить, Да, на ось.
[НА правки 4_3 / 01:15] B: да, я понимаю.
[НА правки 4_3 / 01:15] A: А вот здесь, ну...
[НА правки 4_3 / 01:18] A: Ну, то есть пропущены даты как будто бы,
[НА правки 4_3 / 01:20] B: Да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 01:20] A: видишь, да?
[НА правки 4_3 / 01:21] A: То есть тут, при
[НА правки 4_3 / 01:24] A: том, что даже если убираешь прогноз, то это не помогает.
[НА правки 4_3 / 01:28] A: То есть просто вот как бы эти даты просто пропуски вот здесь.
[НА правки 4_3 / 01:32] B: Снизу, да, посмотреть, что перекрывают дата.
[НА правки 4_3 / 01:38] A: Да, так,
[НА правки 4_3 / 01:39] A: вот смотри.
[НА правки 4_3 / 01:43] A: В целом, вот здесь по поводу цены на первичное жилье вот эти вот изменения, то есть как будто бы давай может быть мы сделаем это все в одной карточке, то же самое что индекс цен производителей, вот,
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:01] B: Да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:01] A: индекс цен на жилье, я тебе присылал индекс цен на жилье файл.
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:05] B: да, я его уже подставил в прогноз.
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:09] A: Это вот она же, да?
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:10] B: Mm
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:10] A: Вот.
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:11] B: -hmm
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:11] A: Мы, соответственно, из него же берем вот эти изменения код года.
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:19] A: То, что ты его не отыщ прогнозика, хотя он показан, что он типа есть, да, но его на самом деле он не показывает
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:25] B: А, я его здесь. лишь из-за того, что навеи добавил, к нему не применилась автоматическая эта штука по выключению.
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:32] B: Выключение.
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:33] A: Да.
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:34] A: А вот смотри,
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:36] A: и может быть я вот думаю, что по факту это же одно и то же, просто разные агрегаты.
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:43] A: Я думаю, что нам надо, знаешь, как сделать.
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:52] A: написать в избежание потребительских цен вот здесь вот
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:56] B: Uh-huh.
[НА правки 4_3 / 02:56] A: вместо ИПЦ потому что мы про это говорили по моему вот и вот здесь еще добавить сам индекс то есть по аналогии с тем то есть вот еще одну кнопочку вот сюда где-нибудь
[НА правки 4_3 / 03:16] A: индекс вот то есть вот так здесь видишь да что я могу посмотреть вот допустим как изменялись цены видишь
[НА правки 4_3 / 03:29] A: да и и вот здесь добавить то же самое допустим изменение год к году
[НА правки 4_3 / 03:40] A: Только не в разных карточках, потому что так получается, если мы надобавляем, то у нас будет дохренища карточек и тяжело будет ориентироваться. То есть мы сюда еще будем какие-то добавлять.
[НА правки 4_3 / 03:53] A: То же самое с индексом цен производителей.
[НА правки 4_3 / 03:58] A: То есть он индекс цен, допустим, хорошо он в виде индекса.
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:02] A: Ты сюда заходишь.
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:04] A: И здесь,
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:06] A: а это я тебе тоже отправил?
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:08] B: Но я все прогнозы, я в целом все прогнозы, которые вы присылали, я их перенес.
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:15] A: И ПЦ помесячные я тебе отправил, да?
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:19] A: Ой, не ПЦ, а эти программы.
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:26] B: Ой, сейчас пропал звук. А, вот появился.
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:31] A: Так, да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:33] B: Что-то прерывается.
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:34] A: вот цены на недвижимость я присылал, да?
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:38] A: Слышно меня?
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:39] B: Да-да-да.
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:40] A: Сейчас, подожди, может быть надо отключить.
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:44] A: Да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:45] A: интернет чуть не очень.
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:46] A: По-моему, я тебе не присылал этот на индекс цен производителей. Я его сделал.
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:54] A: Вот.
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:55] A: Ну,
[НА правки 4_3 / 04:56] A: вот цены на жилье я тебе присылал, надо будет их, кстати, посравнивать.
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:01] A: Вот.
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:02] A: А индекс центразводитель я тебе, по-моему, не присылал, хотя я его сделал.
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:09] A: Вот.
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:10] A: Все его сделал,
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:11] B: Я только
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:11] A: но я
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:11] B: прогнозы
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:11] A: тебе еще не
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:12] B: и
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:12] A: прислал.
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:12] B: ПЦ по месячному присылали, которые.
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:17] A: Да, вот я уже, кстати, сделал и этот ВВП номинальный.
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:23] A: Вот тоже прогноз. Я тоже потихонечку делаю, буду теперь отправлять.
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:30] A: Ты себя помечаешь вот эти вот аналитики?
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:33] B: Да да да да да, да у меня уже 9 пунктов набралось.
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:37] A: Ага,
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:38] A: да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:39] A: вот.
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:39] A: Короче, давай вот индекс цен-производитель, тоже изменение год-году, сделаем кнопочку внутри.
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:46] B: Угу, хорошо.
[НА правки 4_3 / 05:49] A: Потому что это по факту один и тот же показатель, то есть то же самое, вот это год-году цены на первичном, на вторичной жилье, то есть тоже сделаем внутри вот этого вот.
[НА правки 4_3 / 06:01] A: Потому что мы потом еще будем добавлять еще какие-нибудь там.
[НА правки 4_3 / 06:05] A: индикаторы соответственно не хотелось бы раздувать это все вот ну и индекс потребительских цен написается там на услуги там продовольственные продовольственные вот то есть инфляция за год там недельная месячная ну
[НА правки 4_3 / 06:24] B: Угу.
[НА правки 4_3 / 06:24] A: да в принципе что-то тут прогнать ну вот квартальное
[НА правки 4_3 / 06:28] B: На
[НА правки 4_3 / 06:29] A: у тебя квартальное, слетело везде
[НА правки 4_3 / 06:30] B: и я отметил.
[НА правки 4_3 / 06:31] A: получается
[НА правки 4_3 / 06:34] A: Да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 06:34] A: реально эти услуги просто фигачат, как не в себя.
[НА правки 4_3 / 06:40] A: То есть какие-то вообще тут значения.
[НА правки 4_3 / 06:45] A: 12% март, пока подожди, январь 13.9.
[НА правки 4_3 / 06:50] A: Здесь чего?
[НА правки 4_3 / 06:53] A: Слушай,
[НА правки 4_3 / 06:54] A: что-то тут не того. Посмотри.
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:00] A: Вот январь, вот смотри,
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:04] A: январь 25-го года,
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:06] A: значит,
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:07] A: что за декабрь 24-го, значит, за год должно быть 11,5,
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:13] A: за 24-й, правильно?
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:14] A: Открываем годовую, тут 9,5,
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:18] A: то есть что-то не совпадает у нас.
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:22] B: Мне надо посмотреть какую я на год ставил.
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:27] B: А,
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:28] A: Ну, то есть надо посмотреть то же самое вот по этим.
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:32] B: хорошо.
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:33] A: То есть вот, допустим, у нас декабрь 24,
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:38] A: 9,5,
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:39] A: да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:40] A: значит здесь, вот здесь совпадает. То есть вот это совпадает, а вот на услуги давай продовольствие, посмотрим тоже,
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:48] A: допустим, 11,07.
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:53] A: Да?
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:54] B: Угу.
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:56] A: Дети пять.
[НА правки 4_3 / 07:57] A: Она как будто всегда один. Она у тебя от всего одна и та же.
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:02] A: Вот здесь. Она у тебя по факту годовая подтянулась из общей и ЗПЦ.
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:08] A: Вот из этой.
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:09] B: Да.
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:09] A: Она у тебя распространилась вот здесь вот на все.
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:12] A: На все.
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:13] A: Ну и соответственно квартальная тоже как будто бы она.
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:17] A: скорее всего тоже да ну то есть посмотрев этот моментик потому
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:19] B: Хорошо,
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:20] B: я подметил это.
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:22] A: что вот это но вот это вот это конечно побыстрее исправить потому что прям явно то есть пользователь заходит явно видно что как-то мы косякнули здесь мальца вот
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:36] A: тут вот видишь да писаться здесь еще более менее да
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:43] A: Вот.
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:46] A: Это чего у нас?
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:47] A: Ну, не прод, да, не прод,
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:49] A: наверное.
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:50] A: Вот.
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:51] A: То там, конечно,
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:52] A: это самое.
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:53] A: Вот.
[НА правки 4_3 / 08:55] A: Ну и смотри, вот сейчас закончим и будем переходить, я тебе пришлю на индекс цен производителей.
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:01] A: На первичный и на вторичный у нас уже есть все,
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:05] A: да, то есть прогноза, но тут добавим на
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:08] B: Хорошо,
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:09] B: да.
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:09] A: этом мы с тобой уже говорили, да.
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:11] A: Вот.
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:12] A: И будем переходить к следующему блоку. Следующий блок у нас ВВП.
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:16] A: Я бы тут сразу отметил, чтобы мы добавили у тебя здесь только ВВП номинальный.
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:23] B: Mm-hmm.
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:23] A: Да, тоже смотрю ВВП номинальный, да, вот этот вот рост квартал-квартал, год-году, все в одну карточку надо
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:29] B: Да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:29] A: смотреть.
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:30] B: их по сути нет.
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:31] A: И добавить ВВП реальный, что важнее, потому что номинальный, ну тут,
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:38] A: блин, просто за счет того, что цены растут, вот, у тебя он фигачит вверх, да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:44] A: вот, а нам нужно, то есть, больше всего интересует как раз ВВП реальный.
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:50] B: Добавил, ой, написал.
[НА правки 4_3 / 09:53] A: Да, да, и я, соответственно, тебе буду уже присылать вот здесь вот прогнозы, то есть вот эта следующая карточка, по которой мы будем работать,
[НА правки 4_3 / 10:02] A: сравнение, да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 10:04] A: то есть сравнение, ой, у нас подчислилось, да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 10:07] A: допустим, число рождения,
[НА правки 4_3 / 10:09] A: расходы бюджета.
[НА правки 4_3 / 10:14] A: А, и смотри,
[НА правки 4_3 / 10:15] A: у нас вот это.
[НА правки 4_3 / 10:17] A: Демография как будто бы странно, что она у нас,
[НА правки 4_3 / 10:20] A: а не заводишь ли вот индексы добавить?
[НА правки 4_3 / 10:25] A: Вот индексы эти написал, да?
[НА правки 4_3 / 10:30] A: Ну, честность населения, почему она с 2010 года?
[НА правки 4_3 / 10:36] A: Хотя она растать, я там скачал.
[НА правки 4_3 / 10:39] A: Она,
[НА правки 4_3 / 10:39] A: вон, с 1897 года есть.
[НА правки 4_3 / 10:43] A: Правда, не погадан, но она погадан, начиная с 70-го года.
[НА правки 4_3 / 10:51] A: Давай, ну, как бы у нас должно быть преимущество, потому что у нас должны быть длинные, максимально длинные ряды.
[НА правки 4_3 / 10:57] B: Хорошо, да, еще более исторические.
[НА правки 4_3 / 11:00] A: То есть та с 2010-го как-то маловато.
[НА правки 4_3 / 11:06] B: Угу.
[НА правки 4_3 / 11:06] A: По расписанию 1970-го хотя бы.
[НА правки 4_3 / 11:16] A: Обновлялись данные.
[НА правки 4_3 / 11:19] A: Вот.
[НА правки 4_3 / 11:22] A: И что-то хотел сказать хорошего.
[НА правки 4_3 / 11:27] A: Что-то хотел сказать. Что хотел сказать.
[НА правки 4_3 / 11:31] A: Это хорошо, это хорошо.
[НА правки 4_3 / 11:35] A: Ну вот по метрике посмотреть,
[НА правки 4_3 / 11:37] A: наша задача, чтобы нас там, посмотри Google, да?
[НА правки 4_3 / 11:43] A: Вот Google нас хотя показывает.
[НА правки 4_3 / 11:47] A: Видишь, да? Ну прям как мало кто кликает, но как бы мы...
[НА правки 4_3 / 11:51] A: на 30 позиции там в среднем 86 показов сделано в последнее время побольше существенно то
[НА правки 4_3 / 11:59] B: Угу,
[НА правки 4_3 / 12:00] A: есть у нас как бы и если посмотреть страницы которые он индексирует то есть у нас как бы видишь он показывает страницы прям их как статистики он видит вот и тут как бы все нормально то есть он показывает
[НА правки 4_3 / 12:17] A: Я уже рублем заиндексировал хорошо.
[НА правки 4_3 / 12:20] B: Да, но
[НА правки 4_3 / 12:21] A: А Яндекс, скотина, вообще не хочет нас индексировать.
[НА правки 4_3 / 12:28] A: То есть вроде страницы добавляет, убавляет, и он просто нас не показывает.
[НА правки 4_3 / 12:32] B: я я подключил напрямую API,
[НА правки 4_3 / 12:35] B: я вот все,
[НА правки 4_3 / 12:37] B: ну я исправил для того, чтобы я я просто
[НА правки 4_3 / 12:40] B: Поставил в переобход самый главный у нас сайт, ну вот этот файл по разметке страницы. И он должен вот сейчас обойти этот робот. Но я не знаю, может завтра уже обновится.
[НА правки 4_3 / 12:55] B: Но по идее я там доделал все.
[НА правки 4_3 / 12:59] A: Окей, ну вот как бы первоочередное, надо вот эти вот поправить, инфляции вот эти годовые и квартальные, то, что у нас там съехала этот прогноз, вот.
[НА правки 4_3 / 13:11] A: Остальное можно так, ну потихонечку, вот, потому что надо,
[НА правки 4_3 / 13:17] A: надо, видишь, как бы, то есть вот с одной стороны у нас переходы с поисков в систему, у нас сегодня вот рекорд.
[НА правки 4_3 / 13:25] A: ради да но
[НА правки 4_3 / 13:26] B: Угу.
[НА правки 4_3 / 13:26] A: они как-то плохо то есть максимум было 10 до этого сегодня 13 людей то есть ну потихонечку чтобы надо чтобы переходы по рекламе они ну все меньше меньше долю занимали вот в этом самом но плюс да вот вернувшись посетители должны как-то тоже то есть вот если посмотреть у нас есть
[НА правки 4_3 / 13:53] A: Так, а что-то я сейчас тебе покажу.
[НА правки 4_3 / 13:57] A: Общее число визитов.
[НА правки 4_3 / 14:00] A: То есть вот у нас есть некоторый костяк из 60 человек где-то, двое, вокруг мы сами,
[НА правки 4_3 / 14:11] A: вот есть остальные, да, там, которые, ну.
[НА правки 4_3 / 14:15] A: больше четырех раз заходили вот то есть там но во и там 10 20 раз так далее но надо чтобы побольше таких было то есть ну 2-3 захода там 345 человек в основном видишь вот один заход это 4 на 5 тысяч получается вот есть так посмотреть да то есть у нас всего
[НА правки 4_3 / 14:41] A: 5,5 тысяч визитов, да, там 13,5 тысяч просмотров.
[НА правки 4_3 / 14:47] A: Нужно нам попробовать вот как раз,
[НА правки 4_3 / 14:51] A: как бы это сказать,
[НА правки 4_3 / 14:57] A: потому что вот не обнаруживают вот эти файлы.
[НА правки 4_3 / 14:59] A: И ключевые слова,
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:01] A: вот эти description,
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:02] A: title,
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:03] A: то есть это надо им передавать,
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:05] B: Mm-hmm.
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:05] A: потому что иначе он нас одного индексирует.
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:09] A: Есть сайты, которые делают аналитику, может быть тоже их посмотреть,
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:14] A: то есть они тебе что-то там говорят, что что-то у тебя там есть, что-то у тебя там нет,
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:20] A: я вот допустим на какой-то зашел тут,
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:22] A: но он типа платный тоже.
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:26] A: Ну, какие-то он может подсказать что-то там тебе.
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:36] A: Вот посмотри,
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:37] A: видишь,
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:37] A: в Google индексация 62 страницы, в Яндекс индексация 3 страницы.
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:43] C: Почему
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:44] A: То
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:44] C: он только
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:44] A: есть просто,
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:44] C: три?
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:45] A: ну это я вчера.
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:48] A: Ну вот, ну да, может этот сайт тоже не совсем прям все,
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:52] A: но суть в том, что он как будто Яндек джойстик, но не хочет,
[НА правки 4_3 / 15:58] A: ну это было вчера, может быть сейчас он,
[НА правки 4_3 / 16:01] A: ну ему надо какое-то время, чтобы пройти еще раз по сайту,
[НА правки 4_3 / 16:05] A: нужно чтобы этот робот стоит там сайт мэп, ну он подгрузил новый.
[НА правки 4_3 / 16:16] A: Вот.
[НА правки 4_3 / 16:17] A: Ну, то есть посмотрим этот момент.
[НА правки 4_3 / 16:19] A: Вот так что Google нас индексирует хорошо.
[НА правки 4_3 / 16:23] A: То есть вот если, допустим, даже если не верить вот этим всем штукам,
[НА правки 4_3 / 16:29] A: я, допустим, на Google зайду там и там курс евро к рублю график поставлю,
[НА правки 4_3 / 16:36] A: то я могу, допустим, придя там на шестую, седьмую страницу.
[НА правки 4_3 / 16:44] A: найти нас ищем
[НА правки 4_3 / 16:48] D: Mm-hmm.
[НА правки 4_3 / 16:48] A: на сильной странице то есть вот это мы в поиске да понятно что хорошо бы было быть вот если открыть то он сразу выдает график евро вот да там конечно знаешь вот особенно для таких
[НА правки 4_3 / 17:09] A: Хорошо бы было, знаешь, как сделать?
[НА правки 4_3 / 17:12] A: Вот как на инвестинге мне понравилось, потому что, допустим, какой
[НА правки 4_3 / 17:17] E: Для графиков именно вы имеете ввиду?
[НА правки 4_3 / 17:19] A: пример.
[НА правки 4_3 / 17:21] A: Не как трейдинг, смотря, допустим, график евро-доллар, и тут могли это время, где-то время.
[НА правки 4_3 / 17:38] A: Чарт.
[НА правки 4_3 / 17:41] A: Сейчас. Вот я покажу тебе какое-то имею в виду идею какую.
[НА правки 4_3 / 17:48] A: Так, а чё-то она нихрена не это.
[НА правки 4_3 / 17:53] A: Не работает украине Reactive Chart. Сейчас.
[НА правки 4_3 / 18:13] A: Эта фишечка одна мне понравилась.
[НА правки 4_3 / 18:20] A: Что-то он не хочет его подгружать.
[НА правки 4_3 / 18:23] A: Типа, чтобы можно было менять кастомный мост. То есть, видишь, тут три года, допустим, мне три года, но мне хочется покрупнее, да?
[НА правки 4_3 / 18:31] A: То есть, чтобы я мог, тут я могу просто двигать сюда,
[НА правки 4_3 / 18:35] A: да? Может, мне хочется вот только вот этот кусок смотреть.
[НА правки 4_3 / 18:38] A: Если
[НА правки 4_3 / 18:38] E: А может
[НА правки 4_3 / 18:38] A: бы можно хочется,
[НА правки 4_3 / 18:39] A: чтобы тут было может быть два бегунка каких-то, чтобы я мог там вверх-низ.
[НА правки 4_3 / 18:46] A: Вот я бы хотел посмотреть на,
[НА правки 4_3 / 18:50] A: но
[НА правки 4_3 / 18:53] E: оно и не
[НА правки 4_3 / 18:53] A: это
[НА правки 4_3 / 18:53] E: автоматизируется.
[НА правки 4_3 / 18:53] A: как бы не обязательно так вот добавить прокрутку графика влево-вправо, это было. Так вот хочу.
[НА правки 4_3 / 19:03] A: Посмотреть, где ты записывал, делать прокрутку графика,
[НА правки 4_3 / 19:09] A: как на инвестирования. Ну-ка давай я попробую кому-нибудь из, допустим, голод.
[НА правки 4_3 / 19:18] A: Может быть какой-то...
[НА правки 4_3 / 19:22] A: Нифига не эта.
[НА правки 4_3 / 19:28] A: Пропала вот эта возможность,
[НА правки 4_3 / 19:29] A: ну-ка технический чат.
[НА правки 4_3 / 19:36] A: По-моему, они,
[НА правки 4_3 / 19:37] A: видимо, обновили тоже, короче, но как будто бы сейчас.
[НА правки 4_3 / 19:54] A: Давай загружающий код.
[НА правки 4_3 / 19:56] A: Может быть из-за того, что у меня нет пи.
[НА правки 4_3 / 20:04] A: Просто работает.
[НА правки 4_3 / 20:06] A: Сейчас его пьяный, он тоже молчит.
[НА правки 4_3 / 20:09] A: Алло, что он говорит?
[НА правки 4_3 / 20:16] A: И что он хочет?
[НА правки 4_3 / 20:42] A: Ну ладно,
[НА правки 4_3 / 20:43] A: это я тебе потом покажу.
[НА правки 4_3 / 20:45] A: Короче, пока не надо ничего делать,
[НА правки 4_3 / 20:47] A: но суть в том, что видишь, он эту страницу индексирует. Но если ты попробуешь в Яндексе найти хоть по какому-нибудь запросу, там просто можно искать 20-30, ничего не найдешь.
[НА правки 4_3 / 21:03] A: То есть он находит настоку по этому запросу.
[НА правки 4_3 / 21:08] A: и то если слепым написать то есть вот видишь он находит сразу две страницы да именно которые он там заиндексировал то есть вот здесь он нас находит только нужно надо вот либо так прописать либо вот так прописать вот то есть вот есть еще видишь типа какой-то парсер
[НА правки 4_3 / 21:35] A: Ну, смотрите,
[НА правки 4_3 / 21:38] A: есть то же самое, поисковая статистика.
[НА правки 4_3 / 21:40] A: Яндекс индекс, видишь, 8,
[НА правки 4_3 / 21:43] A: индекс Google 62.
[НА правки 4_3 / 21:47] A: То есть, соответственно, Google нас хорошо проиндексировал, да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 21:50] A: ну и вот, соответственно, здесь есть,
[НА правки 4_3 / 21:53] A: вот есть ключевые слова, очень плохо, мы не нашли ключевые слова на веб-сайте. Вот, то есть...
[НА правки 4_3 / 22:04] A: Это описание, да, ну там может быть описание поменьше надо сделать,
[НА правки 4_3 / 22:12] A: но это все не так как будто бы критично,
[НА правки 4_3 / 22:16] A: но то что ключевых слов нет это важно.
[НА правки 4_3 / 22:25] A: На такие платформы можно заходить но смотреть что...
[НА правки 4_3 / 22:31] A: Соответственно, какие-то может быть рекомендации.
[НА правки 4_3 / 22:35] A: Вот для того, чтобы вот у меня какая идея есть.
[НА правки 4_3 / 22:41] A: Возможно здесь писать какое-нибудь короткое описание. То есть возможно его генерить с помощью нишки, как было у вот этого.
[НА правки 4_3 / 22:53] E: А
[НА правки 4_3 / 22:53] A: Так
[НА правки 4_3 / 22:54] E: вот...
[НА правки 4_3 / 22:54] A: вот здесь сейчас.
[НА правки 4_3 / 22:55] E: Угу.
[НА правки 4_3 / 22:56] A: Вот здесь сейчас написано более кастомное, что вот там типа Industrial,
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:03] A: Consumer,
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:04] A: туда-сюда,
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:05] A: а раньше было просто написано, ну как-то просто описание вот этого графика, то есть оно было сгенерировано машинно, шаблонно что ли, то есть без какой-то аналитики и я думаю, что вот такая вот штукенция бы.
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:25] A: просто какое-то словесное описание то есть можно
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:29] E: А
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:30] A: по
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:30] E: по всем
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:30] A: пробовать индикаторам. это как ну да да да то есть по всем индикаторам это бы нас существенно подбустило бы в плане потому что у нас по факту лишь страницы текста нету нифига то есть как бы он не может понять
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:49] A: что,
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:49] A: ну то есть как
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:50] E: А
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:50] A: бы
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:50] E: раз
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:50] A: он
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:51] E: сколько
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:51] A: очень
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:51] E: день ему
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:52] A: подозрительно
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:52] E: менять?
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:52] A: относится.
[НА правки 4_3 / 23:53] E: А раз сколько в день ему менять этот текст? Раз в день или раз в неделю?
[НА правки 4_3 / 24:00] A: Да, мне кажется по обновлению индикатора,
[НА правки 4_3 / 24:06] A: А, то
[НА правки 4_3 / 24:06] E: по обновлению индикатора.
[НА правки 4_3 / 24:07] A: есть какие-то у нас обновляют, то есть как будто как что-то новое вышло.
[НА правки 4_3 / 24:12] A: вот можно добавлять но опять же давай давай этот момент сразу диплоить не будем попробуй как бы какой-то вот допустим на инфляции попробуем пропетировать вот и допустим ну чтобы вот здесь да там чего-нибудь он писал да и вот здесь вверху либо тут вот под картой то есть ну
[НА правки 4_3 / 24:35] A: Он крутит, собственно, наверху, собственно,
[НА правки 4_3 / 24:37] A: что-то писал, но буквально четыре-пять строчек, чтобы
[НА правки 4_3 / 24:40] E: Хорошо.
[НА правки 4_3 / 24:41] A: недолго было это читать, вот, потому что большой текст тоже никто не будет читать,
[НА правки 4_3 / 24:45] A: но это бы существенно бустило нам этот SEO-шку, потому что иначе он видит, что у нас на странице только заголовки и все,
[НА правки 4_3 / 24:56] A: и текста почти нет,
[НА правки 4_3 / 24:57] A: и только вот здесь методология, и, соответственно, для поисковика как будто, что у нас какая-то...
[НА правки 4_3 / 25:04] A: в принципе какая-то фишинговая страница там и так далее вот то есть калькулятор инфляции вроде у нас хорошо сделан но во всяком случае очень ну как бы я вот других калькуляторов видел на и вот вот это вот кстати вот эта тема мне кажется
[НА правки 4_3 / 25:31] A: вот такую
[НА правки 4_3 / 25:32] E: Я еще могу такое к каждому
[НА правки 4_3 / 25:33] A: экстрим
[НА правки 4_3 / 25:34] E: блоку сделать, ну к каждому индикатору подробно.
[НА правки 4_3 / 25:40] A: такую бы да какую-нибудь такую бы штуку но давай попробуем давай попробуем это по тестить начале на одном индикаторе каком-то близко даже упц то есть чтобы это то есть вот это конечно мне кажется
[НА правки 4_3 / 26:01] A: классная вещь то есть она тоже существенно то есть вот нам вот чуть-чуть побольше текста вот эта страница как мне кажется идеально вот это вот вот это мне очень нравится по дизайну по всему и вот по вот этим всяким штучкам
[НА правки 4_3 / 26:19] A: Вот,
[НА правки 4_3 / 26:19] A: и по методологии то,
[НА правки 4_3 / 26:21] A: что есть сейчас, все вопросы,
[НА правки 4_3 / 26:23] A: то есть вот здесь просто какой-то, ну,
[НА правки 4_3 / 26:26] A: как будто какой-то гений SEO работал, как мне кажется.
[НА правки 4_3 / 26:32] A: Вот нам бы чего-то такое же лучше, да, потому что на вот этих вот штучках мало текста.
[НА правки 4_3 / 26:40] A: То есть давай попробуем.
[НА правки 4_3 / 26:42] A: что-нибудь суда запинвью, то есть не надо сразу все деплоид, давай будем потихонечку масштабировать изменения.
[НА правки 4_3 / 26:50] E: Хорошо.
[НА правки 4_3 / 26:51] A: Вот видишь, да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 26:53] A: кстати говоря,
[НА правки 4_3 / 26:54] A: то есть кажется и все делает за нас,
[НА правки 4_3 / 26:58] A: однако сколько вот мы вносим правок и сколько мы еще будем носить.
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:02] E: Да, да, да, вот это я еще на очень хорошей модели просто делаю.
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:08] E: Там другие модели.
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:09] A: А ещё убери вот убери вот этот OLS вот этот вот вообще
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:14] E: Блин,
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:14] A: вот
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:14] E: ну
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:15] A: везде
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:15] E: я,
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:15] A: проверю,
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:15] E: да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:16] A: чтобы вот этих всяких ОЛС чтобы
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:20] E: хорошо.
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:20] A: не этот самый потому что то есть вообще тут ничего чтобы не надо чтобы многооконные там однооконные и так далее вот то есть просто чтобы ничего не было написано потому что тут
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:33] A: Когда прогноз пока недоступен, хорошо.
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:38] E: Угу.
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:40] A: А вот кредиты, ты я видел, ты тоже добавил кредиты, вот давай так и оставим, то есть карточки там юри, только давай не юри, там юрлицам.
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:52] A: Я не так физик,
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:54] A: то есть и LFL,
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:56] E: Непонятно.
[НА правки 4_3 / 27:56] A: потому что для поисковика лучше,
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:00] A: чтобы он, потому что обычно люди пишут физик сами в LFL,
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:06] A: но типа что это для SEO опять же лучше,
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:12] A: как мне кажется.
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:13] A: Вот, то есть тут все здорово, как мне кажется.
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:19] A: То есть у ОНИЛ починилось у нас,
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:21] A: у ТСНИЛС этой починилось, у старта по ипотеке, которая пошла от вверх.
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:27] E: Mm
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:28] A: То
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:28] E: -hmm.
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:28] A: есть тут в принципе все четенько у нас.
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:32] A: Ну и давай вот этим вот как бы надо разобраться с вот этим багом,
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:40] A: с квартальной инфляцией годовой.
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:43] A: И по всем правилам,
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:45] A: вот эти вот как бы кавки, которые,
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:47] A: вот.
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:49] A: А так я пока тоже буду изучать, как еще можно это продвигать, вот.
[НА правки 4_3 / 28:56] A: Потому что пока я вот гоню трафик, вот, оно как бы так устаканилось, но наша задача как бы чтобы у нас какой-то костяк постоянных посетителей сформировался.
[НА правки 4_3 / 29:10] A: Ну, то есть, которые бы сюда заходили, там что-то смотрели по мере выхода.
[НА правки 4_3 / 29:20] A: Вот такие дела.
[НА правки 4_3 / 29:21] E: Хорошо,
[НА правки 4_3 / 29:21] E: все,
[НА правки 4_3 / 29:22] E: я все отметил.
[НА правки 4_3 / 29:25] E: А, Никит Александр, а когда у вас есть свободное время?
[НА правки 4_3 / 29:33] E: Вот я думал по-моему
[НА правки 4_3 / 29:34] A: Сейчас я посмотрю, да, там встретятся.
[НА правки 4_3 / 29:40] A: Давай, так,
[НА правки 4_3 / 29:42] A: сейчас,
[НА правки 4_3 / 29:43] A: сейчас, сейчас.
[НА правки 4_3 / 29:49] A: Это какого в Москве?
[НА правки 4_3 / 29:53] E: 16 мая, ну
[НА правки 4_3 / 29:58] E: и потом 18-го
[НА правки 4_3 / 29:58] A: 16 мая.
[НА правки 4_3 / 30:03] A: Я вот думаю, может быть где-то на следующей неделе, потому что я уже уезжаю в Тулу, после той завтра у меня до вечера пара, после завтра уже в Тулу поеду на майские где-нибудь.
[НА правки 4_3 / 30:18] A: Может быть как-то насчет, ты днем можешь днём?
[НА правки 4_3 / 30:22] B: Да, могу.
[НА правки 4_3 / 30:25] A: Вот я могу днём там допустим.
[НА правки 4_3 / 30:28] A: 5 или 6 числа.
[НА правки 4_3 / 30:33] A: Ты как?
[НА правки 4_3 / 30:34] B: Да, давайте.
[НА правки 4_3 / 30:36] B: Но давайте пятого.
[НА правки 4_3 / 30:39] A: Давай, можно вот у РЭО где-нибудь часка, ну там в час-два вот так вот в обед.
[НА правки 4_3 / 30:48] B: Хорошо,
[НА правки 4_3 / 30:49] B: все,
[НА правки 4_3 / 30:49] B: я себя тоже поставил в час-два.
[НА правки 4_3 / 30:52] A: Вот меня сегодня издернули как бы.
[НА правки 4_3 / 30:56] A: А, начать совещание.
[НА правки 4_3 / 30:59] A: Все, я сейчас тоже пометил тогда,
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:01] A: будем ориентироваться.
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:03] A: Вот. Ну и как бы вот этот постарайся, пожалуйста, быстрее вот этот вот баг поправить, чтобы потом, видишь, мы же его как заметили,
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:09] B: Да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:10] A: то есть
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:10] B: да, да.
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:10] A: вот сейчас посетитель
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:10] B: его бот должен
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:11] A: зашел.
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:11] B: проиндексировать.
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:15] A: Да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:16] A: и посмотрим там, что село у нас.
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:18] A: А я тебя в ближайшее время тогда пришлю прогноз по индексам производителей.
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:25] B: Хорошо, хорошо.
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:28] A: Все, тогда договорились, будем на связи.
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:32] B: Все, хорошо.
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:33] A: Давай,
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:34] B: До
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:34] A: хорошего
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:34] B: свидания.
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:35] A: вечера. Сегодня футбол будешь смотреть?
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:38] B: Не, кстати,
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:39] B: а кто сегодня играет?
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:42] A: Сегодня полуфиналы Лиги чемпионов.
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:44] B: А,
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:44] A: По-моему, кто сегодня играет, сейчас скажу. Кто сегодня играет?
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:51] A: Там вышли либо Бавария.
[НА правки 4_3 / 31:55] A: Так, сегодня играют ПСЖ Бавария.
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:04] A: Атлетика Арсенал играют завтра.
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:06] B: Да, Атлетика, Атлетика Арсенал.
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:10] B: Да,
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:11] A: Они
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:11] B: видел я
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:11] A: завтра играют,
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:12] B: уже
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:12] A: а сегодня после
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:12] B: играли.
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:13] A: себя авария.
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:14] B: А Тоттенхам уже сыграл все, да?
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:17] B: Я смотрю. А, ну да.
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:19] A: Но Тоттенхам, да, уже вылетел.
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:27] B: Не,
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:27] A: Ладно,
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:28] B: а во сколько будет этот матч
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:29] A: тогда в
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:30] B: в 2?
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:32] A: 10 вечера.
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:34] B: А, в 10.
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:41] B: Ладненько.
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:43] A: Все, давай тогда договорились, будем на связи.
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:47] B: Да.
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:47] A: Вот я тебе буду сообщать тогда там по нашей индексации что-то.
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:50] B: Да, да, да. А я параллельно тоже как бы буду там правки вносить и я буду писать.
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:56] A: Все, супер, договорились тогда.
[НА правки 4_3 / 32:59] B: До свидания.
[НА правки 4_3 / 33:00] A: Давай все, хорошего вечера, пока-пока.
[НА правки 4_3 / 33:02] B: До свидания.